welcome back so now we're ready to start
talking about some of the types of
machine learning and kind of categorize
the different methods of different
architectures we have to build models
from data and there are a lot of ways of
slicing this there's so many different
algorithms I mean there's so many just
you know so many flavors of neural
networks alone let alone all of the
other machine learning models but what
I'm gonna do is give you one of the most
kind of common breakdowns of types of
amount so we're talking about types of
nl and the two big distinctions in in
machine learning at least two of them
are whether or not your data or your
algorithm is supervised or unsupervised
so supervised learning means that you
have an expert who has labeled your data
with outcomes so you have labeled
training data and so so in some sense
this supervision comes in the form of
labels that tell you for this set of
inputs this is what the outcome or the
prediction is so I'll give you a very
concrete example let's say I have a
bunch of images of cats and dogs that's
my old dog so maybe I've got a bunch of
cats and a bunch of dogs and I have an
expert human go through and label all of
those you know cats dog cat dot so on
and so forth then a supervised learning
algorithm there is a whole family of
machine learning algorithms supervised
algorithms that will allow me to build a
classifier in so that in the future if I
have a picture of let's say I have a cat
in this case so if I have a picture of a
cat in the future the algorithm can
learn how to label that cat as the
supervisor would have the same way the
supervisor would have okay so that's
what we mean by supervised supervised
learning if your data comes in
categories like cats and dogs and birds
and people then this is called
classification so it's classification
if the data is kind of discrete data
categorical data or it's regression if
if the data is continuous so I give you
an example of classification an example
of regression would be let's say I give
you a bunch of airfoil designs okay so
I've got a bunch of airfoil designs
maybe you know my knack at double-o 12
and an epaulette and so on and so forth
and I measure what the drag is and let's
say the drag is a number it's a
continuous number like 0.3 or 0.4 and so
on and so forth what you would want to
do with a regression model is in the
future if I have a new airfoil I'd want
to be able to tell you oh that's going
to be a point three two drag coefficient
on that airfoil okay so this is
classification for discrete data like
categories dogs and cats or discrete
labels regression for continuously
varying labels like the drag coefficient
on an airfoil okay so that's one big
category of machine learning are
supervised algorithms and there are you
know classification and regression
techniques and another large category is
what we call unsupervised and as you
might have guessed there are no labels
so there's no expert telling you what's
what's different what's a cat what's a
dog what the drag coefficient is you
just get a bunch of data and you have to
make heads or tails of it or cats and
dogs of it okay
and so unsupervised machine learning is
is very interesting this is kind of what
we mean when we say data mining so
you've heard you know data mining we're
gonna take all of our mountains of data
and we're gonna mine it for patterns and
pull out interesting rules that we might
be beyond a human to write down so
that's what we mean here this is what
people talk about with data mining in
some sense if I gave it all of these
pictures of dogs and cats if I gave an
unsupervised Algar than all of these
pictures of dogs and cats but I
hold the algorithm there's two kind of
things you might want to be
distinguishing it might learn clusters
in the data it might learn
distinguishing features that tell dogs
and cats apart and it might learn that
there are these two categories that are
kind of different okay
and so that is is called clustering
again if you believe that your data is
discrete in some sense you will cluster
that data and then you could use those
clusters for a future classification and
then if it's continuous data like like
this case you might use something called
dimensionality reduction that's what I
call it dimension reduction pattern
extraction is another one pattern or
feature extraction pattern extraction
and I should say that each of these kind
of four groups here so classification
regression clustering and pattern
extraction or feature extraction each of
these four areas is a huge huge area of
machine learning there are text books on
classification and regression and
clustering and so on and so forth
thousands and thousands of papers and
researchers in each of these areas and
and that's something you have to think
about based on your data is do you have
labels does an expert has an expert
actually told you this is the thing I
want as an outcome and here's the number
for all of my input data okay a last
area and I'll talk about this in a
little bit I have kind of a slideshow
for for the next segment there's also a
group called semi-supervised and these
are algorithms where maybe there's some
expert feedback maybe you get in
reinforcement learning maybe my my robot
my agent gets a reward but it doesn't
get a reward after every action it takes
maybe after ten actions it gets one
reward so there's partial information it
gets from the environment or from a
supervisor but it has a lot of unlabeled
data as well and it has to kind of bring
these together so reinforcement learning
generative models really fit into the
semi supervised and this is actually
where a lot of interesting work is is
happening because you get some really
very useful models in the
semi-supervised world okay so more on
this soon with a flowchart Thanks